[Music]
hey what's up guys my name is achernar
welcome to another video so I'm at the
top of Mount Feldberg at the moment it's
little mountain here in Germany inch
phosphide you is pretty good last time I
was here it was like 12 degrees and
there were clouds everywhere and the
visibility was nothing I'll probably put
some photos in so you can see but today
it's a really nice clear day summer is
probably like 20 plus degrees so it's
good and today we're gonna be talking
about the differences between making
games and making game engines because I
feel that that's something that well
first of all people ask me all the time
but also something that it's just in
general has changed so much over the
years because in the past I feel like a
game and an engine weren't really two
distinct parts like they kind of are now
like it was fine to have kind of you'd
be building your game and you'd be
programming it and there would be tons
of stuff that you'd be kind of like a
huge framework that you build around
that game and when you ship the game you
kind of move on to another game and I
mean of course you'd reuse code and kind
of maybe assets and components from both
your previous game onto your next game
but you wouldn't really like you
wouldn't exactly you wouldn't you
wouldn't have you wouldn't have that
clear division and distinction between
just a normal kind of game and the
actual edge and the actual core kind of
framework the core architecture for that
game so I think that something that has
changed quite a lot
I almost feel that nowadays the kind of
technology base has stabilized to such
an extent that it it makes more sense to
write an engine and then maybe build a
game on top of that because I mean in
the past if you think about how quickly
games were evolving and how like how
quick new graphics techniques and all
that stuff was kind of coming out people
were kind of just getting to grips with
programming with what the best way is to
kind of structure a game all of that
stuff whereas now I feel like the rate
of innovation in that specific area has
somewhat kind of stabilized so it's not
as it's not evolving as rapidly which
means that we can kind of settle down
create a base framework a base engine
and then kind of work off of that and
maybe ship you know two or three games
or more off that same technology base
before we decide to kind of rewrite it
so that's
definitely something that has kind of I
think improved or I guess just changed
because now it's just the rate of growth
is not as fast so you don't really have
to be continually rewriting every game
from scratch there's more and more code
that you can reuse in also mansion games
are becoming more complex and we also
want to ship more games more often which
kind of all all means that it makes much
more sense to kind of just stick with a
base kind of set of technology and then
build off the off of the top of that
[Applause]
furthermore if you're someone who wants
to make a game right now in 2018 I want
to make a game and you're not a massive
kind of triple-a sized team then you
don't even have to consider building
that base framework because that's been
done for you you can just use a game
engine such as unity and unreal which
comes with so many tools that means the
content creators kind of just make the
game and there's very minimal
programming or scripting that you
actually need to do which again is
something that is a little bit new so if
your goal is to make a game that's such
a different product than if if you want
to make an engine and I feel like that
separation is kind of something that
people do need to consider now that they
might not have had to 20 years ago or
even 10 years ago so it's quite
interesting how the industry has really
changed and how the kind of I guess the
art or the craft of making a game has
changed so much over seemingly not not
that that big of a period of time and so
because there's that distinction of
games and engines I feel that people
need to kind of decide on what it is
they actually want to make because if
you're trying to make a game by yourself
then you should definitely skip the
engine part and just use unity or unreal
I even made a video about a year ago
about why you definitely should be using
a game engine so I'll be a link up there
but on the other hand if you're more
interested in the base technology and
engines that's a completely different
skill set then what then what you need
to actually make a game because nowadays
to make a game you just need to learn
how to use unreal or unity and kind of
programming that goes along with that
which more or less gameplay scripting
right like you don't need to learn how
to program graphics or kind of you know
runtime kind of engine loops or platform
abstractions or anything like that you
don't need to do any of that because
that's already done for you so you
really just need to learn how to
actually design your game and and build
that build a game using the tools that
already exist whereas making the tools
is what engine development is about and
that's just such a completely that's a
completely different topic it's way way
different and the skill set is different
and if you want to get hired for one of
those positions it's gonna be completely
different so I feel like you really do
need to pick a path between the two now
of course you could do both there's
nothing wrong with making an engine and
then making a game with your engine
that's totally fine as well but just
keep in mind that
if your goal is to just make a game then
you should just go ahead and make a game
and skip the engine part now me
personally and what this channel is
about it's about making engines right
it's about making that called core kind
of framework stuff because me personally
I'm not really interested in games at
all I don't play any games in my spare
time like ever pretty much I used to
there was a time when I was maybe like
1718 like I did play games and I thought
that I kind of wanted to make games but
I never really I was never really
interested in that when it actually came
down to making games so I was always
more way more interested in the engine
development and that's kind of what I
based this channel on as well which is
why if you're looking to make games I
mean you should probably shouldn't be
watching videos on this channel and
let's just want general education or
whatever you know for obviously if you
want to learn C++ and it's a good idea
to watch my videos but if you want to
make an end if you want to make an
actual game then you should just watch
someone who makes unity or unreal
tutorials right that's not me this
channel is about making an engine and
making the core kind of framework stuff
and even to the point where it doesn't
even have to be for a game like really
at its core what I like to build and
what we are building here on this
channel is really just an interactive
application with 3d graphics that's
really all it is a real-time 3d a
real-time 3d interactive application a
real-time interactive application with
3d graphics there we go or one more I
can't even talk I really there's people
around me like everywhere and so I feel
like I'm pressured to like because I
don't want to I want to let them pass
and not talk here so they don't feel
uncomfortable so there's all that burn
anyway the point is the ones at the
point that I'm trying to make is on this
channel we're trying to build real-time
3d applications and they're interactive
interactive applications with real-time
3d graphics that's pretty much all I
wanted to say that there is that
distinction and I think it's important
for you to know what it is that you're
kind of trying to do because that's
going to completely change what you
actually learn about and what you
practice and what you master whether it
is that you want to make games or that
you want to make engines leave your
thoughts in the comment section below
I'd love to hear what you think
about that distinction and the best way
is to kind of learn how to do both
follow me on Instagram this place is
beautiful and I'll be posting so much
stuff there and I'll see you guys later
goodbye LinkedIn on Instagram my name is
the Turner by the way link in
description below see you next time
goodbye
[Music]